salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique depuis quelques
temps je m'intéresse aux publications
scientifiques qui mélange les questions
génétique politique et psychologique
alors honnêtement il faut dire ce qui
est une bonne partie du temps ça donne
des résultats
un petit peu aléatoires et souvent on a
envie de dire à ces chercheurs vous
auriez mieux fait d'aller voir des
chercheurs en sciences politiques ou en
sociologie
ils ont trouvé exactement la même chose
que vous mais certaines la publication
ressorti un peu du lot et apporte tout
de même des pistes de réflexion
intéressantes et aujourd'hui je vous
présentais une de ses publications qui
est tournée uniquement vers la
psychologie
il s'agit d'une publication réaliser
enfin une suite d'expériences réalisées
par des chercheurs de l'université de
cologne axée autour de la question du
conservatisme et de l'environnement
laure moysset des conservateurs un
globalement sont moins intéressés aux
questions écologiques et
environnementales que les gens de gauche
ces chercheurs sont partis d'un principe
qui est que les gens de droite et bien
se réfère aux questions d'ordre de
hiérarchie de préservation de la société
et ont donc des référents intellectuelle
tourné vers le passé pour faire
schématiquement c'était mieux avant et
donc ils se sont demandés si eh bien on
pouvait les intéresser à l'écologie en
ayant des discours qui font référence
non pas au futur comme c'est d'habitude
le cas sur l'écologie et les discours
sauver la planète pour les générations
futures et cetera et cetera met donc en
tenant des discours axé beaucoup plus
sur la question de comment et et
l'environnement avant et donc ils ont
mené une demi-douzaine d'expérience sur
la question avec des cobayes auquel ils
ont d'abord demandé de se positionner ne
s'auto positionner sur un axe gauche
droite
alors je vous présentais quelques unes
de ses expériences
qui me paraissent intéressantes tout
d'abord ils ont fait lire les
descriptions écologistes à des cobayes
donc l'une tournée vers le passé et
l'autre vers le futur et ont mesuré le
taux d'adhésion à ces phrases selon que
l'on soit conservateur ou progressistes
et comme on peut le voir sur ce
graphique alors les points individuels
représentent les personnes et les
droites les tendances globales comme on
peut le voir les descriptions tourné
vers le passé intéresse plus les gens de
droite que de gauche et vice versa suite
à cette expérience ils ont également
cherché à voir l'attitude
environnementale pour voir si ces
discours modifier ou pas l'attitude des
gens et comme on peut le voir les gens
de gauche quoi qu'il arrive on une
attitude environnementale assez
importante alors que plus on va vers la
droite et plus cet intérêt à des croix
mais on voit que le discours tourné vers
le passé permet tout de même de
maintenir plus attention des gens
conservateur que le discours tourné vers
le futur
ils ont également fait une autre
expérience assez amusante je trouve
ils ont pris plusieurs photos
environnementale et ont modifié les
légendes
là on peut voir des photos d'un lac
plein et d'un lac asséché
dans un premier cas ils ont dit que le
lac plein était une image du passé et le
lac asséché
une vidéo du présent et dans un second
quart eh bien ils ont dit que l'akp l'un
représentait le présent et le lac
asséché était donc une projection dans
le futur
et là encore comme pour la première
expérience on voit que les conservateurs
sont encore une fois plus stimulée d'un
point de vue environnemental quand on
leur parle du passé donc la première
série de photos qui présente le présent
et le passé que quand on leur présente
des photos tourné vers le futur avec une
simulation de ce que sera le lac et dans
quelques années
néanmoins là aussi on peut le voir plus
on va vers la droite de toute façon plus
l'intérêt d'y croire mais ce discours
tourné vers le passé quand même permet
de limiter la décroissance de l'intérêt
également ils se sont intéressés au
soutien aux associations écologistes
en fonction de leur présentation ils ont
créé de stéréotypes d'associations écolo
donc une première de gauche avec un
discours est une illustration typique de
la gauche avec un slogan tourné vers le
futur et une deuxième donc tourné vers
le passé les reins avec un slogan qui
dit qu'il faut la préserver et bien
l'héritage de nos ancêtres et ils ont
demandé ensuite aux participants de
donner de l'argent à l'une ou l'autre de
ces associations et on leur donnait un
crédit de 50 centimes et là les
résultats sont assez flagrant on a
quasiment des dons en miroir les gens de
gauche ont donné moitié plus d'argent en
moyenne aux associations à l'association
tourné vers le futur que à l'association
tourné vers le passé et les
conservateurs eux ont fait exactement
inverse ils ont donné en moyenne moitié
plus d'argent à l'association
conservatrice qu'à l'association tourné
vers le futur
alors que conclure de ces expériences et
bien que sur certaines questions au
moins l'attitude que l'on peut avoir est
plus lié à la façon dont on nous
présente le sujet
cadets point de doctrine précise sur
cette question écolo clairement on peut
intéresser des gens de droite si on leur
présente l'écologie en fonction d'un
discours qui leur parle en fonction de
leurs référents intellectuelle alors
c'est extrêmement intéressant parce que
ça veut dire que si on veut intéresser
les gens à l'écologie il faut peut-être
arrêter de ne présenter en permanence
greta tout berg qui nous parle des
générations futures et d'une écologie
féministes et des colonials et à la
place nous présenter sa grand-mère qui
nous dit quand même que l'environnement
c'était mieux avant mais au delà de la
question
écologistes et du conservatisme en soit
je trouve que cette expérience apporte
beaucoup d'éléments de réflexion sur la
communication la politique en général
par exemple enfin surtout sur la
question par exemple du populisme ça
fait des années en france notamment que
jean luc mélenchon essaie d'être en
place un discours populiste sans
réellement y arriver sans fédérer les
foules peut-être parce que en voulant
créer un discours pour tous en fin de
compte on n'intéresse personne
est ce que cette expérience montre c'est
qu'on peut intéresser les gens si on
leur parle selon leurs référents et donc
d'un point de vue populiste et bien ça
voudrait dire tout en restant sur une
même thématique et bien produire
systématiquement de discours un tourner
vers les conservateurs qui ne
parleraient du passé et un autre tournée
vers les gens de gauche qui ne
parleraient de l'avenir concrètement par
exemple en prenant la question médicale
ça pourrait être pour les conservateurs
de leur dire eh bien regardez par le
passé comment c'était avant vous n'êtes
pas là qu aux urgences pendant trois
heures les médicaments qu'ils étaient
mieux remboursés et on avait accès à un
médecin plus facilement et puis sur
cette même question de préservation des
services publics de la santé dire aux
gens de gauche
il faut améliorer le service public de
santé l'accès aux soins pour tous et
ouvrir de nouveaux droits sanitaire
également cette forme de discours
différent mais avec un fond commun c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve au moins en
partie je pense dans la question du
souverainisme aujourd'hui je le
souverainisme couvre l'intégralité du
spectre politique
vous en avez de gauche comme de droite
avec chacun des arguments qui parle et
bien à leur clientèle cible tout en
parlant en fin de compte d'un même sujet
qui est le retour de la souveraineté
nationale
en tout cas voilà j'espère que cette
publication vous intéresser et ouvrira
des pistes de réflexion chez vous c'est
le cas et bien n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo est également si vous
trouvez que les vidéos déjà réalisé par
le passé sur cette chaîne sont
intéressantes et qu'un n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner et si vous pensez que cette
vidéo est intéressante et que les
prochaines seront encore plus n'hésitez
pas là aussi à vous abonner et suite à
cette tentative
un petit peu nul de manipulation de la
part et bien je vous dis à la prochaine